so there's a new Star Wars title coming
out very soon and whether you consider
your religion to be Jedi or you love the
movies or maybe you're on the other side
and you're quite skeptical of EA's
handling of the Star Wars license here's
22 things you should know about Star
Wars Jedi fallen order I'm going into
this with uncontrollable positivity
because of the first point Respawn
Entertainment respawn aren't even a
decade old yet and have already given us
the sublime titanfall series which was
sadly Polly advertised and missed his
chance to shine and then they created
apex legends and you already know how
great that game is but again EA's
insistence on overly predatory loot
boxes hurt that game - hmm there's a
pattern here isn't there well now Star
Wars Jedi fallen order is here and we
have been assured the game is a turning
point in the publishers actions as they
attempt to rebuild favor with the
fanbase let's tread carefully here but
the preview suggests that this game
could be great let's start with the
facts fallen order is a completely
single-player story driven action filled
adventure game with occasional RPG
elements but we'll talk about those soon
enough we fill the boots of calque estes
and if he looks familiar is due to the
actor who portrays him Cameron Monaghan
probably most well known for his role in
Gotham my point here is that the acting
of the main character at least should be
of a very high standard which is nice in
Star Wars Jedi fallen order that title
is very long calc Estes finds himself as
the last remaining Jedi but guess what
he's still a Padawan so he has many
skills to learn during the progression
of the game the game takes place about
five years after Revenge of the Sith in
which order 66 has almost completely
wiped out the Jedi but how a Cal has
escaped and now lives in the shadows in
hiding of course that wouldn't make a
very action-packed story so at the
opening of the game Cal is forced to use
his Jedi force powers to save a friend
in danger which leads to the entire
Galactic Empire knowing of his existence
and hunting his Jedi ass down
not a bad start to the story this leads
on perfectly to my next point
new enemies created solely for this game
I know that since
Disney gobbled up the Star Wars license
we've seen more and more new editions
but here in the video game world we get
a few more foes like this purge trooper
purge troopers are expendable death
squads
thanks for Kapadia for that sent to hunt
down Jedi and purge the galaxy of their
existence all thanks to order 66 other
darkside dwellers will be fleshed out
more in this game - including the second
sister a former Jedi turned rogue who
preferred the color red / blue I suppose
she's an Inquisitor that was once
trained by Darth Vader himself making
her a fierce combatant with strong force
abilities so fighting her and her death
squads will be a challenge don't feel as
though the game will only feature
variants of stormtroopers we've seen so
many creatures and other things to fight
that we know for certain enemy variation
is plentiful but also yeah there are
many many many variations of
stormtroopers with many many many
different weapons
[Music]
for Star Wars Jedi fallen order is a
completely linear game which means we
won't be able to turn kal to the dark
side
unless it's already written into the
story we have no agency over the core
decisions and we'll play out a
pre-written experience the exact same as
everyone else playing the game for some
that's a hard pill to swallow but for
the majority of us we just want a great
Star Wars story so we won't see this as
a limitation more of a positive but
speaking of linear older gamers and the
more hardcore of you will know about the
sub-genre of Metroidvania back in the
80s and 90s games like Metroid and
Castlevania and the title made their
games retraceable which means the player
was asked to go back to areas they've
already been through previously in the
game but returning with an item or
ability acquired later in the game will
open new areas to discover and this
theory is continued in Jedi fallen order
which means early in the game you'll see
areas inaccessible until you venture
back in the late game there's a Holy
Trinity of fallen order it's based
around three pillars of gameplay those
are combat which I'm sure everyone is
here for but the other two pillars are
platforming and puzzle solving in a
video I made last week I suggested the
platforming elements play a lot like
Prince of Persia and the puzzle solving
feels much like Tomb Raider but the
closest game to get the entire feel of
fallen order is actually Nathan Drake's
escapades in Uncharted but with a gun
switched out for a lightsaber and a
sidekick replaced with a droid before we
move on from puzzle solving as our Cao
levels up and progresses so do the
puzzles designed to utilize the new
skills he unlocks which then feeds back
into the metroidvania aspect we just
talked about I hope you found something
better out there than this Troy every
new Star Wars story needs a new droids
we've had the cute dustbin we called
r2d2 we've had the rolling pokeball bb-8
iDEN versio had ID 10 and now calc estes
has Biddy one Biddy ones gimmick is that
he becomes a wearable backpack
technology has moved on a long way this
Biddy unit is an exploration box
designed to collect data and the biggest
thing of all he has a spotlight for dark
sections of the game very useful if you
want law simply scan an enemy and bd1
will give
the information random fact about this
droid is that it was based on Woodstock
the little yellow bird from the Charlie
Brown series oh and Biddy one can also
give you heels depending on how you play
that will be very useful so now let's
break down the combat and there's quite
a lot to get through that's it scarf all
inada fights will be similar to Dark
Souls neo or more actually Sakura
shadows die twice that will still be the
opportunity to do a bit of button
bashing in game but as you progress
through the story your skills where the
Jedi lightsaber will be tested for
example enemies have unblockable moves
but luckily they shine bright red to
indicate this action so kal can evade
and this knowledge in combat is vital
enemies will block and counter your
actions instead of flailing around you
will need to think of the battle like a
game of chess paying attention to that
stamina bar which controls the amount of
blocking both cow and your fault can do
slowly knocking down this bar keeping
the pressure on will lead to openings
which then lead to finishes which look
stunning is a few of them
and to finish off our fighting etiquette
we should link this back to progression
and RPG elements ask our levels up he is
rewarded with upgrades and skill points
these award new abilities instead of
explaining them though here's a few of
them from false bushes and poles to
slowing down time to make impossible
jumps
so we've talked about Sakura as a great
reference for mechanics in this game
well to continue this fallen order has a
safe mechanic and you've probably
experienced it before we visited shrines
in Sakura we visited bonfires in Dark
Souls and now kal visits meditation
points to save his progress in fallen
order and just like those other games
visiting these meditation points will
also bring back all the enemies in the
vicinity so use this wisely and grind
your ass off the skill points I'd like
to make a point of law in fall and order
from everything I've read and seen thus
far the law is spot-on and is immersive
and extremely well researched and
designed this game fills in so many
blanks that a typical fan doesn't know
about if you don't read the comic books
or if you don't venture too far away
from the nine core movies this game
brilliantly entwines the core narrative
and politely explains new concepts
without bashing us on the head with a
law hammer so if you want to learn more
about the Star Wars universe whilst
playing something completely new
Baban order looks like it's the right
game for you here's a questionable one
which came up respawn said that there
are no load screens in fallen order hmm
although I doubt that this isn't
impossible they are simply hidden away
have you ever stood in an elevator in a
game yes that's most definitely a
loading screen this will likely be the
role of the ship and fallen order acting
as a hub to upgrade and chat with crew
mates but in reality this is one big
load screen this is unconfirmed but I
thought that was definitely worth
mentioning yeah yeah good to see you too
those places
and whilst we're on our ship let's chat
about it it will be integral to the game
as we can plan it hop we've seen four
planets thus far and at any point once
unlocked we can hop straight back on our
ship and head to another planet we are
not held down and we'll do this
regularly because each time we acquire a
new skill it may unlock a new area on
multiple planets such as slowing down
time to jump through an impossible gap
or simply while running long enough to
reach a new area another thing that has
been confirmed is that we cannot
dismember stormtroopers with our
lightsabers I know I know I'm bumped to
just like the movies the damage is
generalized but on the plus side the
creatures of the world can be sliced
completely in half so if you think about
it every cloud has a scotch lightsaber
Silver Lining that was was a joke
I don't know move on oh let's have a
chat about death mechanics another Dark
Souls esque implementation can be found
when we pop our clocks if an enemy gets
lucky enough to kill your Khal you will
respawn simply fight all your way back
to the enemy and once you take them out
you can reclaim all of your lost souls I
mean all y'all lost Jedi stuff you get
the idea that souls
[Music]
okay to end here's the housekeeping Star
Wars Jedi : fallen hotter releases on
November 15th on ps4 Xbox and PC if you
have EA access or origins access you may
think you're getting it early you are
not
sadly you can only play at the same time
as us plebs if you're on ps4 Pro or Xbox
1x you have the ability to prioritize
performance or visuals performance will
give you up to 60 frames per second and
visual quality will obviously look a
little bit better but will be capped at
30 frames a second if you need some PC
specs I'll put them in the description
below as you'd expect there are
pre-order bonuses should you be
interested in that kind of thing you get
yourself a yellow B skin for your droid
a golden version of the Stinger mantis
ship an orange lightsaber
that's a weird choice but it's there
under mygeeto
and imbalance for your saber I butchered
those words didn't I very sorry and one
last thing I started with this point and
I'm going to end with it to
microtransactions to confirm Star Wars
Jedi fallen order is a single-player
only campaign with no loot boxes no
predatory money-grubbing and no pay to
win
skulduggery let me know how that makes
you feel about EA I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade it's been a pleasure
if you want to talk to me you can get me
on twitter i'm adam grenade over there
my DMS are always open thanks for your
time i'll see you again soon
[Music]